action oh i'm sorry firmware
for a show with so many gags and laughs
you'd be shocked to know there are
hardly any improvised moments
over the course of 12 seasons of the big
bang theory there were plenty of
bloopers
but improvised moments rarely happen
since the script was so tightly written
the few moments were great though one
whispered impromptu line actually
totally redefined a character when were
the laughs we saw on screen scripted
not as often as you'd think let's take a
look
what is everyone at everyone loves a
good star trek reference
but this one really took the cake will
wheaton had appeared in the series as
himself multiple times and
wound up becoming pretty good pals with
the crew game over
moon pie this episode in the ninth
season saw the group of powell's
excitedly attending a star wars film
cue the epic entrance of will wheaton he
took the whole cast by surprise as he
was wearing a full star trek uniform and
was immediately booed by everyone
this was a bit of a spock's sneak peek
since aside from a few writers
no one knew about the trick in advance
resulting in a very memorable and
hilarious moment
what would the big bang theory be
without kevin sussman turns out he
almost wasn't as significant apart as he
ended up being so
how did he go from a small occasionally
seen role to one of the most memorable
characters it was actually all thanks to
an improvised line
let's throw back to season 3 episode 7.
by this time penny had already rejected
stuart but
that doesn't mean he wasn't still vibing
her as penny was leaving in this
particular episode stewart let out a
kind of
whimpering mumble i love you
that one small barely heard line made
all the difference
as the writers totally loved it and
thought it would make a great character
so after that every time we saw stewart
he had that kind of regressive quality
for all of his dialogue which shaped him
into one of our all-time
favorite big bang characters remember
when sheldon had a
well let's call it a wild moment with
amy
are you saying you want to spank me
he was not too impressed with her for
lying about being sick just to enjoy and
relish in the luxurious layman rubs
while it doesn't seem like too big a
deal sheldon felt it was an offense
worthy of punishment and
his go-to well this bit of a
derriere hitting oh my
what's more surprising than that is that
the scene wasn't even in the original
script
and wasn't supposed to be on screen at
all however it happened and made the cut
even though jim parsons had a really
hard time holding it together during
this ridiculous venture
we know there are loads of laughs from
the live studio audience and us watching
at home
but all those laughs we see from the
cast throughout the series
well according to cuoco for the most
part those giggles aren't scripted at
all
the actors had loads of fun shooting
especially with the energy of that live
studio audience
so much of the time they couldn't help
letting a few laughs slip
through to the planetarium let's go
this has definitely been a huge part of
the authenticity in the acting we see
speaking of laughs all those times that
cuoco wound up crying from laughing so
hard
how about those tears of emotion
regardless of what kind they were most
of the time those special moments were
also improvised
for cuoco the show became such a huge
part of her life so
it was hard not to be passionate and
invested in the stories that they were
telling
oh that's gonna make me cry
how about this dinner scene with
bernadette penny and raja's potential
fiance anu
tell me about raj let's just say this
probably isn't the answer she was hoping
for
raj is like so much fun to hang out with
it's no
i mean he is but no penny definitely
didn't do raj any favors with that
lackluster and kind of ambiguous answer
this major awkward moment resulted in
loads of laughs for the audience and
cast alike
whose line is it
this was a case of a silence that went
on a bit too long
so much so that bielik straight up said
she didn't know who was supposed to be
speaking
i don't know whose line it is after the
silence and
lots of laughs the responsibility fell
on johnny galecki who was the one
missing a line all along
thank goodness an assistant handed him a
script to get the team back on track
things were awkward for everyone when
leonard and penny broke up but
we all know it was the hardest on
sheldon of course it would be
remember when penny really went out of
her way to make sure she and sheldon
could be friends and made him that
delicious meal of
spaghetti and hot dogs well you cut up
hot dogs into little chunks and mix them
in with the sauce
apparently while shooting sheldon was
very touched
so touched that he forgot what he was
supposed to be saying completely
um i don't know or maybe the spaghetti
was just that good
either way penny just went ahead and
enjoyed her pasta leaving sheldon
totally hanging it's okay this tastes so
good
no one gets between sheldon and his mint
condition comic books but
in the peanut reaction episode we saw
penny push her luck
threatening to draw on one of them
sheldon do you understand the concept of
blackmail
well of course i oh as sheldon went on
and on explaining the importance of
these very special comic books
it seems penny got a bit lost so she
wound up having no option but to ask
what her line was
once howard and bernadette had halle
there were plenty of regular visits with
the whole family
remember this scene when howard decided
to move a sleeping halle to a bedroom
for a bit more quiet
well on his way he had a bit of a fumble
knocking right into the chair with
little sleeping halle
what really made this moment was how
nervous and shocked he looked after the
incident which caused
everyone to crack up it's not just the
actors who improvise and have bloopers
of their own
the live studio audience made things
unpredictable each episode
anyone remember when penny and leonard
moved in together and looked forward to
being free to do whatever they wanted
whenever they wanted sheldon's not here
so we are going to put on music
and dance in our underwear well that
included dancing in their underwear and
they
went for it though not everyone was as
happy as they were
i'm sorry she said ew a definite way to
throw any actor
however galecki and cuoco were really
good humored about it and laughed it off
they even went so far as to point that
audience member towards the exit
their house their rules speaking of
moving in
let's throw back to when sheldon and amy
took that big leap and slept in the same
bed together
while we can't say we were surprised to
learn that sheldon makes plenty of
noises while he's sleeping
an odd mix of snoring and loud awkward
sighing
enough to drive anyone crazy
[Music]
while bielik managed to get through the
scene for the most part both she and
parsons couldn't help but
laugh right through it
everyone forgets a line now and then but
this particular scene on this particular
day proved to be a bit
too much for mayambilic who couldn't
remember when she was supposed to speak
or what words she was meant to say
your turn am i supposed to say something
for such a smart woman she was pretty
lost in this scene while shooting
the amount of science terminology and
speech that happens in the series makes
for some hilarious mistakes and
forgotten terms
that m a equals mg and what do we know
from this
considering it's hard enough for us to
even catch and understand all that
sheldon amy and the gang say
we don't blame them their experiment on
k on decay supported
our i don't remember the word when
working on such a tightly scripted
series with all the pressures of a live
audience
slip ups are bound to happen please i
may be scared of
butterfly butterflies but but for one
actor in particular they were pretty
frequent
any guesses as to who that might be none
other than kaylee cuoco
so you've been using it probably doesn't
help having so many eyes on the actors
while they're shooting
that pressure is intense with such a
stellar cast
brilliant writers and 12 years of
establishing the big bang theory world
it's no surprise there were so many
laughs all the science terminology
definitely makes for plenty of flipped
lines with rumors of a reboot floating
around we're
keeping our fingers crossed we'll get to
see more of these hilarious characters
on screen
soon